neben man dieses hamburg er pulsiert tag
und nacht
der hamburger hafen kulturstätte
wirtschaftsmotor und sehnsuchtsort
[Musik]
wir begleiten schweizerinnen und
schweizer die in der metropole am wasser
leben und arbeiten
mal mit dem strom mal gegen den wind sie
alle sind an die elbe gekommen um hier
ihr glück zu finden
der hafen ist für sie weit mehr sein
arbeitsplatz ist abenteuer heimat und
hoffnung auf ein anderes leben und dort
oben im norden
ein riese im morgengrauen die mein
schiff 1 bahnt sich vorsichtig ihren weg
auf der elbe
es ist eines von 200 kreuzfahrtschiffen
die hamburg 2017 anfahren
[Musik]
wir haben
mit an bord der schweizer gian luca kern
der in indien aufgewachsen ist
immer in meiner hamburg kommen ist das
schön zum einlaufen sehr sehr schön
und hiervon die brücke haben eine schöne
blick auf der caddy haben spezial st
pauli und so die reeperbahn wo aus schön
ich kenne mich in husum von der guten
alten
und jedes mal wenn man sie laufen immer
ja wie schön dass hamburg lich ein glück
[Musik]
während die mein schiff 1 die elbe
hinauf fährt erwacht hamburg zum leben
auch giuliano ist schon früh unterwegs
er hat heute einen wichtigen termin
ein letzter moment der ruhe gleich
beginnt das casting für die rolle im
musical aladin ja das wird muss man
sagen so was kann die schilde und
klischees und zeigt es dass interviews
bilder und dann ist ja da ist und dann
sterben in deutschland aber das gefühl
ich alles sowieso erstmal und einzige
völlig anders vorbereitet ich los ganz
schlimm also immer verschieden
noch hatte seine nervosität im griff
aber ich glaube so baute der teenager
und dann die ganze kollegen und andere
tanzen sind dann merken an der us küste
war weiß gott mehr sieht dann immer dann
zur bewusst ist einfach dann ein anderes
land seien auch erste und bis dato
gestanden
für juliane wäre das engagement wichtig
um weiter in hamburg arbeiten zu können
doch die rollen sind umkämpft und die
konkurrenz ist groß
auch im hafen wird es ernst heute findet
auf mein schiff 1 der sogenannte
bettenwechsel statt 2000 passagiere
gehen von bord 2009 checken ein
[Musik]
gianluca kern startet seinen
morgendlichen kontrolle und gang als
sanitation officer ist er für die
einhaltung von sicherheits- umwelt- und
hygienerichtlinien verantwortlich vor
dem auschecken bekommen die passagiere
noch ein letztes frühstück an bord
schnell die temperatur abchecken wenn
die prothese ist wunderbar sie schwer
gerade wunde was
der sanitation officer ist gründlich
hier ist alles in ordnung
auf zur nächsten station hygiene hat
oberste priorität
besonders in der bordküche bakterien
verbreiten sich schnell auf einem
kreuzfahrtschiff wäre dies besonders
fatal
schon ein einzelner krankheitsfall
könnte zur epidemie führen
du bist sie mit grad
dass ich noch mal ins meeresgrund höfe
sie wenn sie spirale bakterien und so
dass das alles eben mal etwas
[Musik]
dann trieb es immer nicht
während einige gäste in den kabinen noch
schlafen herrscht auf der pier bereits
reges treiben
das gepäck von rund 2000 passagieren
muss von bord gebracht werden
oberhalb des hafens liegt das
treppenviertel von hamburg blankenese
hier zeigt sich die stadt hügelig der
süllberg misst immerhin fast 75 meter
thomas ist auf dem weg zu einer
verabredung an der elbe
[Musik]
so ich habe die schweizer wm mitgebracht
mal gucken ob das grund gebe auch
schmeckt katrin mcclean ist autorin und
hilft thomas immer dann wenn er mit der
stückentwicklung nicht weiter kommt
gerade so ein bisschen eine geschichte
geht gerade ein bisschen unter
geht ja um diese kreuzfahrtschiff auch
nicht geschichte spielt er da drauf ich
habe meine figuren da ist ein es geht um
einsamkeit weil sie stets allein an der
reling guckst aufs wasser und denkt so
etwas also was ist ebenso habe ich das
jetzt ja zum beispiel das ist genau an
sagt er genau dass er genauso vielfach
und warum geht das stück ist gut einmal
so kann man sich ich habe man so eine
frage satz gehabt für dafür wie viel
einsamkeit braucht der mensch einsamkeit
oder alleinsein ja eben genau das ist
eine frage an kreativ treffen vorhafen
panorama passende zu thomas neuem stück
theater theater genau du wolltest mir
erzählen was hast du alles schon gegeben
weißt du schon wieder ein stück losgeht
ja also meine idee ist ein ganz großes
also ein opening zu machen was gibt es
ein ganzes kathrin und thomas feilen an
den charakteren des stückes was ich
tanzen gehen dafür dass ich dafür drei
gläser wein trinkt hab ich lustig sein
diese fragen aber das ist ja genau und
das ist doch eine schöne frage weil ich
habe gerade so gedacht ihr habt ja
eigentlich in allen euren stücken immer
so eine kleine rote linie so eine
grundfrage diese durch die also
vielleicht können wir da mal gucken
ich finde so ein anfangs motiv so
spannend so also was braucht der max
sozusagen um vielleicht auch also wie
kann das zu kippen also gibt es so eine
situation wurde damit einmal auf das
schiff ist und plötzlich sich selber
entdeckt was sie nachher aber sehr
analytisch die gerade nachsagen
dank der übernahme ich das gut in die
figur ist so und so agiert das hätte im
hausmüll kriege
für thomas sind diese kreative
nachmittage enorm wichtig um mit seinem
stück voranzukommen den spielort der
schiff story hatte direkt vor augen
die hansestadt geht nicht nur wegen des
hafens als attraktiv auch als
medienmetropole lockt sie menschen an
die elbe mehr als 13.000 unternehmen aus
dieser branche haben hier ihren sitz
saralisa schäuble arbeitet gerade an
einem weiteren artikel für das szene
hamburg magazin und es läuft gut wie sie
traten fluchtversuch staat saralisa
schäuble freier journalist in ihrer
webseite bot einfach entscheidet ich
mach das jetzt so und das selbstbewusst
sie hat sich auf das sonst übliche das
hat habe ich viel von anderen irgendwie
so damit dass ich einfach sagen ich bin
das jetzt und auch anagramm ihr mich so
zu verkaufen
und weil ich ganz trainer momentan
sara lee saß letzte geschichte war
paddeltouren in hamburg ist gerade
frisch erschienen mit ehemann frank
hatte sie unterschiedliche touren
getestet
heute sieht sie ihre story zum ersten
mal in gedruckter form
das ist der beruf mache derzeit ein
fotograf gemacht und mir hans bittl
hobbymäßig noten dazu erklärt also das
heißt hobbymäßig hat sich am besten ein
foto gemacht war qualitativ aber
anzustellen ich es immer schön ist aber
mit seinem kopf hat nach einer irgendwie
druck und erklärt dass es andere in
kraft und lassen und das ist so cool
wenn man am kiosk ist aber nach annaburg
danach so das magazin
wenn wir darin kompliziert hat und nimmt
das ganze land schätzt anzusehen aber
nicht
der hafen und vor allem st pauli haben
dass sarah lisa angetan auch
journalistisch
die nerds die große geschichte ist über
st pauli und soziale abseits vom fasten
und reeperbahn wird 100 und schafft es
sie möchte hinter die kulissen schauen
den mikrokosmos st pauli unter die lupe
nehmen
aber dabei immer auch neues wagen das
musical casting ist früh zu ende
jedenfalls für julian
den job hat er nicht bekommen nach der
ersten runde war für ihn vorzeitig
schluss
der erste anruf gilt seiner frau
was soll ich ganz gut stehen und dann
versucht und das ganze
sie habe ich das immer so erzählt sie
und das auto und musste also schicksal
wie es beruflich für ihn weitergeht weiß
giuliano momentan nicht die rollen in
hamburg sind besetzt vorsprechen so
genannte auditions gibt es nur selten
die kollegen kennen das problem
der ziemlich krasse heute richtig sind
doch alle gleich so tun
alle raus dass er als riesige säle
wissen genau wenn sie suchen weil ich
glaube jetzt gehen sie zwei drei leute
und ok ich ja auch beste manchmal so als
wenn man als fünf stunden lang tanzte
und sehr am ende heißt es um eine blonde
leute aber ich bin aber noch nicht ich
bin ich noch nie
es gab wirklich auch tänzerisch sehr
erhitzen wirklich tolle tänze
wir machen das besser gemacht ich glaube
nicht verrät kommen
[Musik]
bis zur vorstellung am abend sind es
noch einige stunden giuliano hat zeit
zum nachdenken
wie soll es jetzt weitergehen ja ich
wieder so unterschiedlich was man hat
ihm ist für extreme und einzigen wo
angebracht von der kammer hat sie aber
das safer sex video stellen bis die
drachen stehen jetzt wieder überholt wie
wir von passiert ab und machte job da
sowohl die scott und
wird vorwärts
sanitation officer gianluca kern im
bauch der mein schiff 1 bevor die neue
ware kommt müssen die lagerräume
inspiziert werden
und dein gott zurück zu keiner zeit habe
man kann man alles wurde da leute das
alles im datum ist und durch und da ist
die hauptsache dass es einen ablauf
gerüche der heimat auch wenn gianluca
sohn eines schweizer generalkonsul es
nur selten in der schweiz war der
50-jährige arbeitet inzwischen seit 33
jahren auf see jetzt oder schiff noch
fast leer ist suchte auch nach blinden
passagieren das schiff wenn es schifft
bewegt und dann sagen sie ja die rate
rennen springen aufeinander aber an
gästekeeper und energien also ich bin
tief bewegt dort keine ratte für die
contra touristen geht die reise zu ende
ihre koffer warten bereits im terminal
[Musik]
an der pier geht es derweilen in die
nächste runde
proviant muss an bord auf hoher see da
später nichts fehlen
das löschen
hier ist ja
[Musik]
unter strenge aufsicht von gianluca kern
wird pallett für ballett an bord des
kreuzfahrtriesen gebracht er prüft ob
die kühlkette auf dem transport
eingehalten wurde und ob die waren
frisch sind deco bleiben nur noch wenige
stunden zeit dann muss die mein schiff 1
schon wieder auslaufen
in ottensen hat thomas besuch aus der
schweiz
seine mutter und ihr mann ferdinand sind
nach hamburg gekommen für das ehepaar
geht es auf kreuzfahrt
das gesprächsthema am kaffeetisch mutter
priesters erfahrungen auf ihrer letzten
schiffsreise als ferdinands i krank
wurde und sie sich alleine fühlte und so
ist wenn ihr sagt ständig für uns so zu
der befindlichkeit die aber nach veganes
stück macher und oder max und was denn
auch persönlich dazu
[Gelächter]
dieses mal soll die reise für mutter
priska und ihrem mann besser laufen
da war niemand da der apa
am terminal wartet bereits die idee
prima bevor es an bord geht werden die
koffer aufgegeben
die linke seite ja links
dankeschön
im terminal ist es dann abschied nehmen
franziska machens kurz und schicke
liefert ali zieme und sogar kreuzfahrt
was seine mutter nicht weiß thomas hat
eine überraschung parat
er wird seine mutter auf der reise
begleiten das nur ein kopf rollen
kraft hatte
flussabwärts richtung elbmündung des die
leiterin des hamburger hafen museums
solarien berger unterwegs zu einem ganz
besonderen termin
[Musik]
hierauf der peters werft will sie ein
stück maritime geschichte besichtigen
das nach langer abwesenheit wieder nach
hamburg zurückgekehrt ist willkommen
vielen dank freuen uns sehr heute die
täglichen besichtigen fangen und weil
den aktuellen zustand mannschaft
der hamburger vier master peking soll zu
einem neuen wahrzeichen des hafens
werden für solarien berger ein höhepunkt
ihrer karriere
[Musik]
es ist wirklich ein traum dass es wieder
nach hamburg kommt weil die findet so
ein hochleistungs objekt wenn man sich
vorstellt 1911 so 115 meter langes
schiff aus stahl zu bauen mit vier
masten und das fuhr 18 knoten mit einer
enormen geschwindigkeit da über die
weltmeere arm cup fahren
was die männer da an bord geleistet
haben wenn das schiff kränkte und die
ladung zu laden und zu löschen
ein traum dass so ein objekt erhalten
ist freue mich sehr dass wir das wieder
hinkriegen einigermaßen mit peters werft
und ihrer hilfe der legendäre p liner
lief einst bei der hamburger
traditionswerft blohm & voss vom stapel
40 jahre rottete sie vor sich hin
zuletzt in new york joachim kaiser
verfolgt die geschichte des schiffes
seit langer zeit 1976 das erste mal auf
der peking gewesen waren weiß sind ernie
l oder der 200 jahrfeier der usa in new
york an den riesen parade
und da war ich an bord und das stand 18
am heck peking hamburg das ist durch ja
richtig war aber wahrscheinlich so
verdammt noch mal wieso liegt hier ein
bisschen haben wohl aber von solcher ist
die mental romantischen aufwallung bis
hin jetzt fange man da nicht ein halbes
lebensalter dazwischen j j
die peking gehört zu den letzten großen
frachtsegler die es anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts wegen ihrer
geschwindigkeit mit dampf und motor
schiffen aufnehmen konnten
der viermaster transportierte salpeter
von chile nach europa wenigen
originalteile aus holz an deck die alten
geblieben sind über 100 jahre alt und
wie man sieht mangels pflege aber
teakholz ist eben ein server was am
längsten überdauern kann nadelholz wie
das holzdeck oder so wird einfach nicht
so
[Musik]
das passiert
nach aufwendiger restaurierung soll die
peking als besuchermagnet an der
kaimauer vor dem hafenmuseum festmachen
[Musik]
wir werden hier die hauptmaßnahmen
machen wie eben unter schiff und
takelage aber das ist noch längst nicht
das ende der fahnenstange sondern wir
müssen sehr viel auch dann noch später
an ertüchtigung und restaurierungsarbeit
leisten und das machen wir nicht auf der
werft fall dass zu viel geld kosten
würde
das machen wir am hamburger hafen museum
ich freue mich auf jeden fall auf 2020
wenn das schiff schwimmfähig hoffentlich
dann zu uns kommt und ich vielleicht
auch mal selbst hand anlegen
einst markierte die peking die
technologische spitze der regeltechnik
vergleichbar mit modernsten
containerschiffen heute
[Musik]
die riesenpleite teilen sich heute den
hafen mit fähren ausflugsdampfer nen und
kreuzfahrtschiffen
[Musik]
beim boxenstopp der mein schiff 1 in
steinwerder wird klar schiff für die
nächste reise gemacht
die gepäckträger warten auf den
startschuss
es geht los
das spiel beginnt von neuem 2115
passagiere geben heute ihre koffer auf
jedes gepäckstück wird durchleuchtet
während die ersten koffer an bord rollen
unternimmt gianluca kern einen letzten
kontrollgang durch die kabinen des
ozeanriesen
[Musik]
anschließend geht es ins grill bistro
mache ich es verstehe warum
danke den wir finden ja
dass das sind jetzt die fritsch
temperatur da wird jede tafel und simon
in der wahrheit so an der demo meter
ausgerüstet mit und endet alles
kontrolliert und materie
die branche wächst rasant deshalb
arbeiten auch immer mehr schweizer auf
kreuzfahrtschiffen
wenn man so schweizer in der schweiz
werden
dann treffen sich für den drink oder so
und ein dritter schweizer die am
terminal warten inzwischen die
passagiere
manche schon seit stunden sobald die
gangway freigegeben wird heißt es
zunächst kabine suchen
das zweite ziel die bordrestaurants
hinterm tresen arbeitet ein
internationales küchenteam
in der multinationalen kreuzfahrt welt
hat auch gianluca kern ein zweites
zuhause gefunden
[Musik]
davon habe ich schon alle gesehen würde
ich sagen weltweit aber dass einige
mitglieder des neues treffen in neu
delhi und das ist schön und dreimal in
indien eine frau die plantage und nur
kleine tochter zur und ich schau gut
dann haben die vier monate schafften
vier monate und zwei monaten frei was
auch gut ist ein bis zwei monate zwei
monate und dann heißt selber leute und
pink und wir haben uns ziemlich schön
[Musik]
der hafen und seine menschen inspirieren
auch sarah lisa immer wieder zu
kreativen ideen
neben ihrer geplanten reportagen st
pauli hat sie ein neues projekt das sie
mit freundin anna besprechen will
[Musik]
sarah lisa und anna wollen ein neues
stadtteil magazin entwickeln
das hat unsere idee ist es fans ins
wasser voll und für st pauli und haben
als er stecke mir vor panik wie lange
ist das her
drei vier wochen oder so ackermann damit
beschäftigen und schon gemerkt dass man
irgendwie voll die gleichen
vorstellungen und ideen hat und dass der
suppe kurzer passt was für mich so
schöner st pauli will aber mehr als
eigentlich nicht kennt für das projekt
findet man sich dann so zusammen und
geht dann halt irgendwie so eine schöne
zusammenarbeit mit selbstverständlich
finden themen müssen recherchiert werden
außerdem gilt es schrifttypen zu finden
und das layout zu planen
[Musik]
saralisa hofft mit der idee noch eine
weitere nische im umkämpften printmarkt
hamburgs zu finden
als thema und erst sie ungehorsam und
das ist besonders bischberg sie warum
ist ja geleitet so das thema irgendwann
krieges so eine sms oder anderen sie
meint so ich habe überlegt ungehorsamen
ganz ein geiles thema fürs erste heft
nicht so gekauft
also wir wollen uns zum beispiel jetzt
mit dem mit dem pastor hier von sankt
trinitatis treffen mit thorsten morche
der hat ganz stark in diesem viertel
auch drin ist und der hat viele menschen
kennt mich interessiert immer das was im
detail passiert und das ist natürlich
perfekt da nur ein stadtteil hat und so
ganz klar weiß wo der erfolgt oder
aufhört und wird
irgendwie als wird aber wenn man so
einen ist ein schmelztiegel hat auch
ganz ganz ganz viele geschichten und ich
sowie gold schöpfer so ich glaube
geschichte liegt auf der straße und die
einer prima wird bald auslaufen
fast alle passagiere sind an bord bis
auf überraschungsgast thomas
[Gelächter]
alles gut ausgeht also auch sofort sagen
alles klar kommen in die schule geht
ich darf mitfahren
thomas hat früher selbst als comedian
auf einem kreuzfahrtschiff gearbeitet
dieses mal darf er sich unterhalten
lassen und entspannen
danke
[Musik]
er wird von seiner langjährigen freundin
heike begleitet sie wartet schon in der
kabine auf ihn
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
darauf macht super kommt ja genau das
ist ja hier vorne ist ja direkt schon
einmal so hoch und da liegt es an uns
zurück
es ist doch grant und einmal sogar
wohnung ja schon da oben
das theater ist direkt da drüben einmal
nur so hoch wie schon bei uns im theater
es folgt der große überraschungsmoment
[Gelächter]
ich frage mich schon mal mehrere mit ihr
mit dir in führung gebracht hatte und es
ist extrem schwer frau das wirklich für
heimliche die ganze zieht jetzt ausschau
nach der platz sauber team im sauberen
park ridge und sauber wo ich und phase
und nachher also nicht für blackberry 6
extrem schwach sind und daher nicht mehr
wir machen jetzt eine richtig schöne
jahre eine woche auf hoher see für die
vier kreuzfahrer geht es auf
entdeckungstour zu den häfen europas
[Musik]
st pauli steht für ungebremstes
vergnügen und die sündigster meile der
welt
und doch lieben die menschen die hier
wohnen ihr stadtviertel am hafen
genau darüber will saralisa schreiben
sie trifft sich mit protagonisten vor
ort viktor hacker ist ein bekannter von
hier seit gut 30 jahren türsteher auf
dem kiez ist eine von sechs st paulianer
die sie porträtieren wird die polizistin
von der reeperbahn oder der kiez becker
sarah lisa will geschichten über
menschen erzählen identifiziert mit
ihrem stadtteil als andere liegt das
mache den hamburg und der grund das hat
ja verknüpfen dass szene sitzen artikel
über sagt felix loch hat aber die hat
schon ein bisschen peter hahn eigentlich
wo oder zur post hat
der kiez ist laut und dreckig aber er
ist eben mehr als rotlicht er ist auch
heimat
wie leben die menschen am kiez wie
lieben und leiden sie und warum sind sie
da geblieben
[Musik]
bist du denn auch nichts gekommen es
ging witzigerweise so immer wenn ich
habe in verschiedenen gastronomien
damals hinterm tresen gestanden und
immer wenn irgendwo ärger war bin ich
dann immer hin und hab irgendwie es
geschafft die leute zu deeskalieren
eigentlich das ist eine gewisse klasse
haben im magazin im tagi dann waren sich
darin fragt oder darüber nachdenkt so
hettenbach einer verlaufen also gute
geschichte ist dann war mir darüber nach
das ist eigenen labor danke und so das
könnte ich mir übers bachelor oder über
meinen schreibtisch so dass mein
anspruch an geschichten
saralisa in ihren anfangszeiten in
hamburg auch unweit der reeperbahn
gearbeitet
im jachthafen einer schummrigen
szenekneipe
das publikum auf den hamburger berg ist
ein anderes als das publikum vorn auf
der reeperbahn der reeperbahn sind viele
touris die laufen da so durch guckte
sich alles mal angehen hier vielleicht
mal rein da mal rein und gehen dann
wieder weg das heißt da konzentriert
sich das eigentlich auf eine bestimmte
zeit auf 2 34 stunden und hier auf dem
hamburger berg geht die party bis
morgens die geht richtig lange einfach
das mache ich lieber und mittlerweile
mit einem freier schafft von als
journalistisches genau das was ich will
olivia jones eine horde touristen und
jede menge hamburger meile wandelt sich
aber die anziehungskraft bleibt wenn
über hamburg die nacht hereinbricht und
sich die im musical vorhänge senken
herrscht auf der elbe stossverkehr
tausende besucher müssen mit der fähre
ans nordufer gebracht werden
auch hinter den kulissen ist endlich
feierabend
für julian und seine kollegen ist
schicht ende
bis eben standen die musical darsteller
noch auf der bühne und begeisterten das
publikum
jetzt werdet ihr ruft durch die ganze
energie das ganze tanzen und singen und
reaktion vom publikum ist durchmischt
energie braucht aber das ist übrigens
mini partner internes gemurre und tut
mal so der riederinger der herrlich
lustig
der letzte im musical schotte wartet
bereits heute wollen die kollegen
zusammen noch einen drink nehmen ihre
gemeinsame zeit das ensemble auf der
bühne geht bald zu ende
das hat de frühjahr hofft macht das
theater und ich spiele von anfang an bis
sie und also für mich jetzt alle sache
sie so auch wieder abschied vor dem
verbot der abschied von den kollegen
mächtig für einerseits halt wie jetzt
traurig sie nehmen wieder zu es wieder
verlag und man weiß ja nie mehr wieder
und anders ich bin ja froh auch für den
kopf für den krippenmarkt auszahlen also
wer es wird schwierig aber ich bin ja
sowieso irgendwie abgestufte zu forscht
wahrscheinlich teilweise ok hat er schon
so oft macht und er frage sich schon
aber man wird sich eben im arm haben
heute abend wird ein letztes mal
gefeiert mit einem lachenden und einem
weinenden auge
[Musik]
für den moment heißt es abschied nehmen
vom theater an der elbe doch für
giuliano wie auch für alle anderen
schweizer im hafen hamburg geht das
leben weiter
giuliano hat im nächsten sommer ein
engagement in thun im musical mamma mia
saralisa wird in zukunft für die nzz us
freelancern von hamburg aus für die
rubrik reisen und entdecken schreiben
der intendant der hamburgischen
staatsoper georges delnon plant mit
seinen schützlingen die zauberflöte in
der hamburger partnerstadt shanghai
aufzuführen
kapitän jack nicklaus ist nach wie vor
im seemannsheim aber regelmäßig auf
heimaturlaub in der schweiz bei seiner
tochter und den enkelkindern und thomas
sein theaterstück steht kurz vor der
premiere